You can program a smart key fob for your
2015 2016 Chevy Suburban yourself,
potentially saving money. This involves
synchronizing the fob's transponder with
your vehicle's immobilizer system.
First, ensure your Suburban is off and
all doors are closed. Insert your
existing working key into the ignition
and turn it to the on position, but
don't start the engine.
Simultaneously press and hold the lock
and unlock buttons on the new fob for
about 15 seconds.
The vehicle should beep or the lights
will flash. Turn the ignition off.
Remove the key and repeat the process
for any additional fobs you want to
program up to a maximum of eight.
Finally, test each fob by locking and
unlocking the vehicle to confirm it's
properly programmed. This method uses a
rolling code system. Each use generates
a new code to prevent replay attacks.
Precise timing is essential for success.
If the DIY programming fails, common
issues include incorrect timing during
the button presses or a low battery in
either the fob or the vehicle. A fully
charged vehicle battery is crucial. If
you've lost your original working fob,
you'll likely need a dealer tool to
erase the old codes. While aftermarket
programming tools exist, using
incompatible ones can brick the fob,
requiring a costly dealer reset. Before
attempting DIY programming, ensure the
replacement fob is compatible with your
Suburban's ECU, which you can typically
verify via the driver information
center, DIC. Keep in mind that while DIY
is feasible, professional reprogramming
is recommended for complex issues to
avoid voiding warranties or causing
further malfunctions. Store your key
fobs in a Faraday bag to protect against
relay attacks, especially in public
areas.